et peut-être que on s'apprête à voir un
certain nombre de changements de vote
sur l'article 7 hier
pour ceux qui ont voté le décalage de 62
à 64 dans l'air il y avait quelque chose
sur l'aménagement des carrières longues
dans l'esprit de beaucoup il y avait si
tu as commencé vous avez commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans quand vous aurez
fait vos 3 ans de cotisation vous
pourrez partir on se rend compte que
c'est pas le cas et qu'on va se
retrouver dans ce tableau qu'on a vu
dans Le Parisien tous il y a quelques
semaines avec ce truc incompréhensible
de toi c'est 43 toi c'est 44 selon la
date à laquelle tu vous avez démarré à
travailler
profondément incompréhensible on se
retrouve dans une situation on doit
voter ça et moi le premier je vais me
retrouver demain dans une
circonscription canton on va me dire ben
moi c'est quel âge maintenant ça va être
44 pourquoi mais j'ai pas compris je
peux pas vous expliquer donc un il y a
la notion de la commande de la justice
de l'équité entre les uns et les autres
et deuxièmement il y a la question de la
visibilité et alors qu'il y a des
notions financières je l'entends mais on
l'entends tous parfaitement mais dans
toute réforme un il y a la compréhension
et deux il y a le degré d'acceptabilité
il y en a qu'on payait cher de d'aller
trop loin et de ne pas trouver ce point
d'acceptabilité ça me semble un point
extrêmement important vous avez commencé
à travailler avant 21 ans 43 ans de
cotisation pour la ligne c'est clair
c'est simple et c'est juste merci
[Applaudissements]